这是Al Brooks,这是我质量行动的质量
这个模式是我的设置
很简单,我用了一个线线线
而且不太便宜,很便宜
我用了一个5分钟的线线
和20分钟的线线
我没有用过任何设置
例如,这边是
一条单单的EWZ
我用了一个20摄氏
和20摄氏
每一摄氏
20摄氏
5分钟的线线
5分钟的线
PBR
PETROBROCE
5分钟的线
20摄氏
2分钟的线
这边是20摄氏
20摄氏
15分钟的线
60摄氏
这条单是
我会从
一条单
是在60分钟的线上
所以它是方便的
所以在这里
你可以看到市场在60分钟的线上
是在60分钟的线上
所以如果这是60分钟的线上
这会是60分钟的线上
我保持着我的线上
我没有打电话
我没有看电视
我通常会打电话
我女儿的女儿
我儿子的女儿
我会打电话
不然的话
我没有打电话
我离开消息
我离开联系
我认为
在7时的报告
或是FOMC的报告
当报告发生了
我通常不在联系
至少几分钟
可能几分钟
我认为联系
报告的意思是
会有一个丰富的
丰富的
他们会发出一个联系
那丰富的
会是丰富的
或是丰富的
那不告诉我
两百 三百个
丰富的
在商业上
觉得市场在做
与报告的运动
我只知道
市场的运动
对报告的运动
是
在看电视的线上
丰富的
只给我一边
我也不想
有什么迫害
我没有
任何人的想法
我只想
去谈谈自己的
我也很关心
我
我的工作是
很简单
是
帮助其他人
帮助其他人的
我都在玩
同一游戏
没有 secret
每个人都在帮助
每个人
Goldman Sachs
在帮助 Morgan Stanley
在帮助 City Bank
在帮助 Everybody else
那就是我们的游戏
我
有60-40个
许多
有时候在电视
你会看到
人家的
市场是绝对上升
绝对上升
或是
或是下降
没有任何事
所有事
每个事
有些事
很多事
40-60%的时间
所以我认为
我们在世界中
有40-60%的可能性
阿伦红尔
曾说过
他很高兴
他在时间中
在70%的时间中
所以
他在市场的
帮助其他人
他在做许多
他在控制游戏
甚至在那里
他仍然可以
在时间中
在70%的时间中
所以
很多的责任
在世界中
会有40-60%的可能性
如果你想
有些事比那些
你可能是错的
如果你想
有些事比40%
你可能是错的
如果有些事
在那里
他们不会是
在其他市场的
帮助其他人
他们会把货带回到
货带
记住
市场
有些事
会有
一个数字
差不多
一个数字的
许多在一边
像在其他市场里
如果市场
有些事比在其他市场里
会有些事比在其他市场里
如果有人说
他有些事比60-40%好
有些人在电视上
会说
有些事比
我从来没有相信他们
任何人
是
那些
确定
或确定
他不是正确
他在外面
在卖些什么
完美货带
不可以存在
因为
有些人在其他市场里
要有些人在其他市场里
如果有些人在其他市场里
完美地写
那意味着
其他市场里
会必须得完美地写
因为这些
市场里
是非常平衡
在两个市场里
那些是
不可能
这些事
如何
费用
如果大家知道
费用很难做
即使你很好的
你的货币
是很小的
每个错误
都会对你
你会知道
最好的
评论
只有
60-70%
左右
我经常
有时
我没有失误
对吗
这不意味着
我100%
对
这就是
我当时
很幸运
真的好评论
我最多
不会对
70%左右
不过
他们是费用者
我费用
很多时间
我经常
在日常
但是很多人
都是费用者
这就是
最高的
你对
世界最好的评论
最好的评论
人在世界
基本上
是一场
每个人
都想费用
每个人的钱
好
有很大的差别
在认知
如何做什么
真正的
还能够
做一个生活
你
一个阳光手
他可能知道
如何玩
例如一个教授
但
他不可能
做一个生活
做这个
你可以知道
很多人
在认知
但是
你必须
有很多
经验
能够
认知
能够做一个生活
谁是
与
如果你不相信,對方的對象會發生40%的時間
你會被捕捉到壞的位置,而不得了好位置
你必須要很有情緒地在這方面,和你的信息
你必須要改變,當市面給你明確的證據
你的信息現在錯了,就把對方的信息取得
沒有錯,市面一直在改變
一直在改變,一直在改變
所以你必須改變你的信息,一直在改變
能否被捕捉到壞的位置?
當然
這裡有一個強大的捕捉
然後有幾個強大的壞處
有些捕捉會出現在這壞處
尤其是這兩條處
如果你是一個壞處的壞處,然後看到壞處
就把這壞處捕捉到壞處
如果你是一個壞處的壞處,你就把這壞處捕捉到壞處
你不會覺得很恐怖
這是市面的方式
你會看到壞處的壞處
如果你看到壞處,你會覺得很錯誤
你會覺得壞處,壞處,壞處
還有另一個壞處,你不要擔心
這是最後的 module 設定